as we all know the SCP Foundation
secures contains and protects the
various anomalies under its custody but
their mission isn't limited to just
grabbing the object and chucking it into
a containment Locker at the bottom of a
classified site deep below the surface
of the Earth the foundation wants to get
a comprehensive full understanding of
all the strange items creatures and
humanoids in its custody because that's
the only way to understand what they're
capable of what danger they pose and how
to effectively contain them that much is
logical but the problem is that there's
no Global scientific Community
surrounding anomalies at least not ones
willing to cooperate with the foundation
perhaps the chaos Insurgency or Global
occult Coalition have some scientists
who have studied anomalies or the
various government agencies that know
about the anomalous world like the
unusual incidence unit or Soviet grup
but for the most part the foundation is
utterly alone when it comes to figuring
out how these anomalies work what they
are and how to combat them so the
foundation does what any institution
would do experiments many of the
foundation's most important and iconic
anomalies are defined by the experiments
the white-coated scientists have
performed on them sometimes even using
human subjects through the notorious and
Infamous d-class program everyone knows
about how scp-682 the hard to destroy
lizard has been subjected to practically
every known weapon and attack Under the
Sun in an attempt to kill the highly
dangerous hateful predator and who can
forget scp-914 the Clockworks and the
countless objects the foundation has put
through it on its five settings to see
what it spits out needless to say the
foundation's experiments are incredibly
important to how the organization
functions so those scps that can offer
lots of testing options are very
treasured and prized along with being
iconic and legendary out the foundation
today we're going to be looking at one
such anomaly but not a dangerous hostile
man-eating Predator like scp-682 or a
mysterious Eldritch machine like scp-914
now today we're going to be looking at
something much more simpler than that a
coffee machine yes today we're going to
be inspecting
scp-294 affectionately referred to by
guards and personnel as the coffee
machine though you probably don't want
to order a hot cup of joe in this coffee
machine lest you well let's not get
ahead of ourselves the first thing you
see when you open the scp-294 file is
its number of course item 294 object
class Euclid the next thing you see is
the image if you were imagining a tiny
little coffee maker before this should
get rid of that
scp-294 is big the kind of coffee
machine you'd see in a factory break
room it's almost the size of a vending
machine and has a big colored window
showing a few cups of coffee along with
the slots for cash and coins so drinkers
can pay for their espressos but the most
notable feature on scp-294 is the full
keyboard on the front panel it's a
typical qwerty keyboard just like yours
with a space bar and everything why on
Earth would a coffee machine need a
keyboard the special containment
procedures paint an interesting picture
by which we mean there aren't any
scp-294 doesn't need any special
procedures secret rituals or complex
machines to keep it contained but it's
still Euclid so only Personnel who have
security clearance of level 2 or higher
are allowed to interact with it at the
moment this is surprising when you
realize that scp-294 is currently being
held not an anomalous item Locker or
containment cell but exactly where you'd
expect to find a big coffee machine a
break room specifically the site 19
second floor Personnel break room but
it's not alone
it's monitored by two guards with level
3 clearance around the clock for them
sitting in the break room all day
guarding a coffee machine that can't
move and is too heavy to lift has to be
a pretty sweet gig considering what
other kinds of jobs are available at the
foundation but all that raises even more
Mysteries what the heck is up with this
coffee machine the description starts
off obvious enough affirm that yes
scp-294 is indeed a standard coffee
vending machine but with the difference
we all noticed earlier instead of a
simple button list of options it has a
full keyboard on it each button aligning
with the letter on a real keyboard and
when someone slips 50 cents into the
coin slot quite a bargain for coffee if
you ask me the user gets a message on
screen prompting them to enter the name
of what liquid they'd like you type it
in on the keyboard and that's that the
machine drops a little paper cup and a
nozzle shoots out 12 fluid ounces of
whatever you requested pretty nifty
isn't it but it gets niftier most people
would only think to ask a coffee machine
for well coffee but scp-294 accepts any
liquid and some things that aren't
liquids when the foundation initially
got their hands on it they ran no less
than 97 tests on it after they realized
they weren't just limited to espressos
and cappuccinos at first any kind of
liquid you could drink was requested the
researchers popped in requests for water
coffee Beer soda milkshakes and out they
came then they decided to get a little
more creative they started to request
things you couldn't possibly drink not
if you wanted to stay alive sulfuric and
hydrochloric acid like the kind scp-682
is suspended in wiper fluid motor oil
but scp-294 stubbornly provided even if
the liquids would melt through the
researchers throats like a knife through
butter then the researchers decided to
apply some of their scientific knowledge
there are a lot of chemical compounds
that don't usually exist in a liquid
state on planet Earth's surface they
typed in nitrogen iron and glass among
others and received shimmering liquids
in paper cups they sent them off to a
lab for analysis and wouldn't you know
it chemically identical to nitrogen iron
and glass but when they typed in Diamond
no doubt wondering whether they'd found
an infinite Cash Cow they received an
error message on the screen it seemed
that while scp-294 could deliver
substances that aren't usually in a
liquid state on Earth's surface it
needed to be at least possible for the
substance to be in a pure liquid form
for scp-294 to dispense it since diamond
is only a mineral it couldn't be
dispensed then they tried to test
something else and got a slightly
disturbing response on the small LCD
display out of stock it stopped
responding to requests for over an hour
then made a small noise and began to
accept requests again it appears that
the machine can take about 50 requests
before needing to take an hour and a
half to restock itself and while only
the machine is anomalous the small 12
ounce paper cups it dispenses its
liquids in seems remarkably hearty
substances that would have eaten through
paper instantly like these sulfuric acid
and hydrochloric acid had no effect on
these little cups though the same can be
said for those that drank from them one
of the researchers had a great idea here
was an anomaly that was practically
harmless and could be a great little way
for the foundation to scale back its
budget a little bit they propose putting
scp-294 into the break room it currently
resides in both to more easily conduct
experiments and to save money when
agents and doctors came in for lunch and
needed a quick drink or in the mornings
where everyone was looking for coffee to
wake them up with no good reason not to
the machine was put in the break room
but not long after an unfortunate
incident occurred one with enough harm
that it was deemed necessary that only
personnel with security clearance
interact with
scp-294 what could have happened to
cause this did someone burn themselves
on hot coffee did the vending machine
accidentally Crush someone no the
reality is much darker one morning in
August of 2005 agent Joseph whose full
name has been redacted to preserve their
identity went up to the vending machine
in the break room looking to get a hot
cup of coffee to wake himself up between
shifts another agent in the room who is
on break at the time saw him and made a
suggestion to find out what scp-294
would do when given the colloquial name
rather than the exact real name of a
drink they just wanted to see what would
happen so agent Joseph slipped in two
quarters and typed in a hot cup of joe
seconds after he began sweating like a
pig he was feeling very hot even though
the break room was fully air conditioned
and his skin began to flush he then
clutched his head complaining that he
was dizzy and the whole room was
spinning around before collapsing to the
floor the other agent immediately called
the medical staff who Moved agent Joseph
to the infirmary and stabilized him once
they made sure he wasn't in any real
trouble they also grabbed whatever
scp-294 had spit out it was a disgusting
thick reddish brown liquid with a strong
stench and when they ran the labs on it
they confirmed it was exactly what they
thought it was a mixture of blood tissue
bone marrow cerebrospinal fluid and
other bodily fluids that was an exact
DNA match for agent Joseph
scp-294 somehow managed to literally
liquefy 12 ounces from the agent's body
before producing them into a cup this
offered a clue maybe it stole the
liquids it was asked for from the
nearest source in any case the agent was
released after a few weeks of bed rest
and care to make make sure he wasn't
further injured and both involved agents
were reprimanded with the knowledge of
how accidentally dangerous scp-294 can
be who can blame the foundation for
wanting to keep a careful lid on it
researchers were curious though and
received clearance to test the scp's
abilities to retrieve specific liquids
from long distances with an o5's
approval and oversight they input a cup
of
scp-075's secretion
scp-075 the corrosive snail is exactly
what it sounds like a gross little
creature that secretes a highly Caustic
Acid capable of melting almost anything
without fail the coffee machine
dispensed the secretion into the cup and
the cup stayed perfectly intact but at
the very same time in scp-075 cell the
creature woke up and began secreting
acid that immediately disappeared all in
all about 12 ounces the same amount in
the cup based off these results further
testing with scp-294 was approved one
researcher tried punching in a request
for a cup of gold what came out was a
small paper cup of molten gold that
quickly cooled to room temperature
asking for cups of silver and platinum
produced similar results but based off
of previous tests it seemed clear that
the machine wasn't creating precious
metals so much as siphoning them off
from somewhere else the next request was
a strange one a cup of anti-water the
machine took a moment then printed a
small message on its LCD display out of
range this confirmed that the machine
couldn't produce substances that didn't
actually exist and couldn't break
physics to get its materials by peering
into alternate universes Dimensions or
realities after that the researchers
tested for diamond and got the result
that you already know of and out of
range error some more investigations
show that all solid substances that
don't have a liquid form get this error
but asking for a cup of liquid carbon
produced exactly that because liquid
carbon isn't the same thing as a diamond
though both are made of carbon
scp-294 clearly has more knowledge of
chemistry than some of us then the
researchers created an entirely new
drink made of bleach various sodas
protein powders and spices they blended
it together and put it in a jar across
the room from scp-294 when requested the
amount of the liquid in the cup was
missing from the jar proving that
scp-294 doesn't actually create its own
liquids but how does scp-294 react when
presented with a more subjective request
one researcher asked for the best drink
I've ever had after a moment the paper
cup filled with something that looked
like Cola but the researcher said it
tasted like a drink he had years ago at
a party and that he'd always remembered
as his favorite drink though he couldn't
say what was in it but that was a
subjective test test and the researchers
repeated it with a different subject
when an agent also requested the best
drink I've ever had the machine produced
a simple Vienna lager with a label
showing a group of people drinking it at
the beach and no brand name the agent
confirmed that the best drink he ever
had was a Vienna lager at the beach with
his friends so scp-294 could not only
read people's minds it can read memories
they don't even know they still have
another one they tried was something
Cassie will like referencing
scp-085 the young girl who lived in a
drawn on world the cup dispensed was
completely empty but it had a small
drawing printed on the side of a soda
glass with brown and white things
floating on top of each other the
researchers presented the cup to Cassie
and were told by her it was a chocolate
banana milkshake and a delicious one at
that a cup of music was a strange
request and produced an even stranger
result a clear odorless carbonated drink
that tasted vaguely alcoholic when drunk
subjects said they could feel it and
started showing an affinity to music
being able to sing and dance to a rhythm
when they had no sense of Rhythm or were
tone deaf before whether scp-294 can
produce even more abstract Concepts is
still under study but was interrupted by
the next test an unfortunate Containment
Breach incident at site 19 left several
Personnel trapped in the break room
heavily injured while mtfs fought to
re-establish control over the site an
agent typed in a cup of medical
knowledge and the Machine quickly
produced a green liquid after drinking
it the agent was able to treat the
injuries of their fellow Personnel
consistent with standard first responder
practices and was commended for The
Bravery but their knowledge didn't stick
around after the breach and attempts to
recreate the liquid failed they decided
that scp-294 broke its own rules for
self-preservation in the emergency
implying that it's not only sentient it
is intelligent a doctor using scp-294
made a request close to him my life's
story while nowhere close to a drink
scp-294 seemed to accept the input until
it started shaking violently and making
odd noises it remained in this new state
for about three minutes then returned to
normal spitting out a completely opaque
black fluid like tar in a cup despite
the strange reaction the doctor drank
the fluid and immediately informed the
others he was now able to remember
everything that had ever happened to him
from the smallest childhood event to the
most important events in his adult life
he excused himself and disappeared into
his office the next time the staff saw
him two days later he was carrying an
autobiography 600 pages long then the
researchers decided to try their luck
and input surprise me the resulting
solution was a cup containing What
seemed to be regular water right until a
researcher touched it it was just water
all right but it had been superheated to
200 degrees Celsius while remaining in
liquid form the moment someone touched
it bang it violently evaporated into
steam spraying boiling water everywhere
not only does scp-294 have intelligence
it has a sense of humor albeit a quite
rude one the next three requests were
for blood namely blood of the Smilodon
or saber-toothed tiger of the passenger
pigeon and a Founding Father Thomas
Jefferson but the only thing scp-294
produced were out of range errors
confirming it can't take liquids that
don't exist anymore but in the next test
blood was received from wolves saliva
was received from horses urine was
received from koalas and cerebral spinal
fluid was received from foibromus
Patterson Eye a rodent that went extinct
some 8 million years ago though if
scp-294 is working according to its own
rules it may means that there may be
still one in the wild somehow for the
next test the researchers decided to get
back to the scientific roots of it all
they made a request for a cup of
d151839s leukemia knowing that the
d-class in question had a very Advanced
case of cancer the machine outputted it
without any trouble and Analysis of the
liquid showed it contained cancer cells
that match the d-class's DNA but another
request for the same spat out and out of
range error what's more a medical
checkup on the d-class revealed that
their tumor was completely gone but
unfortunately it was only a short-term
fix the cancer cells recurred within two
weeks of the test
scp-294 initially just seemed like a
boring magic vending machine but it was
only after the extensive experimentation
that you just saw a shortened log of
that the SCP Foundation was able to
discern its true nature it wasn't an
unthinking object it was sentient
intelligent and even a little sarcastic
stick though none of that stopped it
from doing its job providing people with
a hot cup of whatever they needed to
drink just make sure you type in your
request very carefully now go watch how
not to kill an SCP
scp-1609 remains of a chair and living
ice cream van
scp-1386 for more oddly sensing objects
and entities secured and contained by
the SCP Foundation